وقال منسق السياسات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص لشرق الاوسط بريتش
مورك يزور الدوحه لاجراء مباحثات بشان
توصل الى اتفاق لاطلاق سراح الرهائن في
غزه والتوصل لهدني اضاف كيربي ان اسرائيل
اتخذت خطوات للتحول الى عمليات اقل حده
واكد ان الاداره الامريكيه حثت المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين على توخي الحذر والدقه
لتفادي سقوط الضحايا المدنيين في غزه
نجري مناقشات رصينه وجاده جدا ونحن
بالتاكيد نريد ان نرى هدنه انسانيه اخرى
حتى نتمكن من ادخال المساعدات واخراج
الناس ولكن ما مدى اقترابنا من ذلك وكيف
تبدو معاير ذلك وعدد الايام هذا كله جزء
من المناقشات التي نجريها الان اتخذ
الاسرائيليون خطوات لنقل عمليتهم لقد
ازالوا فرقه من القوات هذا عدد كبير من
القوات ويقدر بالاف الجنود وهم ينفذون على
الارض عمليات اكثر استهدافا ضد القياده
بشكل خاص انهم يعتمدون بشكل اقل على
الضربات الجويه العمليات منخفضه الشده لا
تعني عدم وجود عمليات مكثفه وحتى في بيئه
منخفضه الشده مره اخرى ستظل في حاله قتال
لا يزال هناك قتال وسيظل هناك
ضحايا ننا من حيث ف الكاتب المختص الشان
الاسرائيلي هاب جبارين
ا اسمح لي ان ابدا من من كيربي سنعود
لتصريحات الاسرائيليه لكن هذا المقطع كان
ملفت وربما الملفت فيه تضارب
اي التضارب مع الموقف الاسرائيلي اسرائيل
تعلن عن توسيع العمليات سواء في خانيونس
او في مناطق اخرى و وترتكب مجازر
حتى المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض كان يندد
باستهداف قبل قليل مراكز الانرو وك يتحدث
عن اتخاذ اسرائيل لخطوات للتقليل من حده
المعارك
وسحب قوات والتقليل في الكلفه
البشريه ثم هو يناقض نفسه في هذا التصريح
ويقول ان تقليص العمليات لا يعني عدم وجود
عمليات مكثفه ما الذي تفهمه من الرؤيه
الامريكيه للعمليات
الاسرائيليه نعم تحياتي استاذ محمد وصباح
الخير يعني بطبيعه الحال هنا يجب ان ندرك
واقع حقيق لا لا يعني لا مفر منه ان
الاداره الامريكيه تقوم باستراتيجيه جدا
بسيطه من ناحيه هي لديها نفير كبير من هذه
الحكومه وا لديها وبل ترهق عائق مهم امام
تحركاتها الاستراتيجيه في داخل الشرق
الاوسط وتحديدا في ظل هذا العام العام
الانتخابي في داخل الولايات المتحده من
جهه ولكن من جهه اخرى هي تقولها بملء الفم
لن تتخلى عن اسرائيل في اي في اي من
تحركاتها نعم هي تريد ان تضر بسمعه هذه
الحكومه هي تريد ان تضرب هذه الحكومه هي
تريد ان تقوم بكل ما تقوم به لكي تسقط هذه
الحكومه ولكنها لا تريد ان تسقط اسرائيل
هذا هو واقع الامر وهذا ما يصرح به كيربي
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر بكلمات اخرى ندعم
اسرائيل ولا ندعم حكومه اسرائيل وبالتالي
هذه التصريحات والتضارب فيما بينها وفي
اجزاء معينه فيها يعني بعضها قد ياخذ
الطابع السياسي الذي يضرب ايه يعني حكومه
نتنياهو وتحركاتها الاستراتيجيه وعندما
يكون الحديث اكثر عن التحركات العسكريه
يكون اكثر لطفا وا اكثر رفقا باسرائيل
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر